hello everyone this game was a
suggestion from a subscriber mr.
supernova 1 1 1 and since a lot of you
said that you would enjoy a game from
from a less known player I decided to
give this one a go as that previous
video by kabocha which really took up a
lot of my time so the game was played in
2016 it was the women's Chess Olympiad
in Baku Azerbaijan we have a game
between Mario Florencia Fernandez and
women's Grand Master meter high as it
were of Iran and Maria here although
she's not feed a rated well although I
think she is now but she was a women's
national champion in Argentina in 2009
and 2013 without having a feed a rating
although her rating in Argentina was
somewhere around 2150 maybe even 2200 so
definitely quite a matchup for her so
let's see this game
maria has the white pieces and he/she
plays d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
nimzo-indian defense yeah I forgot to
say that even though she wasn't
federated when she won the Argentine
national championship
she did she did win the entire
tournament without losing a single game
and her opponents were some
international masters and women
international masters so quite an
achievement definitely ok so we have a
bishop to before the names o Indian
defense something that appears quite a
lot on this channel for some reason we
have a three Bishop captures Abby
captures and the d5c capture Sun d5e
capture Sun d5 and III black castles
here we have Bishop to d3 and c5 and the
standard standard move here is something
like knight Knight to e2 going for the
famous Kerris variation followed by b6
but instead of 92 maria goes for f3
restricting then at the moment of this
Knight and allowing him to jump to e4 g4
and
preparing maybe to push efore in some
variations so we have b6
now Knight to e2 Bishop to a6 and white
castles rook to e8 night the g3 and
immediately Mitra goes for h5 this
Knight is somewhat awkwardly placed on
g3 so definitely an idea would be to
kick it away with age for Bishop
captures on a6 Knight captures on a6 and
Queen to d3 and here major plays Knight
to c7 you don't want to push h4 just
immediately you know this is a better
left as a threat than to execute it
immediately because after 9f5 the Queen
on d3 is guarding the night and f5 the
knight is threatening to capture on h4
so this would be kind of pointless for
black as well after Queen d3 night to c7
Bishop to b2 and immediately c4 and this
does seem like a justified decision
kicking the Queen away from d3 the Queen
goes to e2 and now this Bishop does seem
poorly placed on b2 and this c4 pawn
pretty locked locked down this opponent
c3 and that the bishop doesn't really
have a role here he will either have to
be developed by pushing efore and
through Bishop to c1 or maybe maybe by
pushing a forum playing Bishop to e3 but
the will see night the e6 Queen to d2
now as if the Queen stays on e2 Knight
to f4 is a terrible threat the pawn is
pinned and after the Queen moves Knight
comes to d3 and this will be this will
truly be a monster night Queen to d2
night to f8 now preparing to remain over
the Knight to g6 rook 81 Knight to g6
now Queen to c2 now definitely preparing
to pushy for rook to e6 Bishop to c1 we
have Queen to e8 and it seems that this
Queen to d8
stops a white from playing efore
but to really see why you do have to
calculate a lot if
white were to push efore here then h4 is
coming you first have to get rid of the
night the night is also defending e4 and
after a move like Knight to a5 he
captures any four F captures on e4 you
can't capture with the rook if Rock
captures then White has this night the
d6 move forking the rook and the Queen
and you either have to move the Queen
and lose the rook or you captures rook
on e1 and you give up the Queen for for
a piece and the rook so if you don't
want to do something like this you would
have to capture with the night after F
captures on e4 you have to capture with
the knight on e4 and this leads to
Bishop to h6 and this is this is quite a
variation after G captures on h6 as you
were threatening to capture and g7 d5
the rook has to go to e5 rookie five and
now Knight captures on h6 would check
King to g7 now Knight captures on f7
again attacking the rook after the rook
moves to e7
now you capture the night rook captures
on e4 and after rook captures Knight to
d6 again forking the rook and the Queen
and after Queen moves Knight captures
and after Queen captures on d5 it's a
it's a pretty cool position white is a
little better here but you know it can
go either way so I don't know if Maria
calculated this and didn't go for a four
but okay after Queen to d8 she played
Queen to a5 and Mitra pushed h4 since
the Queen is now occupying f5 better to
get rid of the knight now so the knight
can never jump to get to f5 Knight to h1
was played Queen to a for preparing to
double up rooks on the e-file and this
is this is in fact in an indirect way
stopping efore if efore then Queen to c2
and the pawn on e4 will be pinned but
Maria plays efore anyway Queen to c2 is
played now that pawn is pinned
if pawn captures then Queen captures
Queen night to f2 Queen captures on
c3 and okay black black one upon here we
have e five Knight to d7 and rook to d1
now protecting the d4 pawn and here
meter played b5 and this isn't something
something that is really in the spirit
of this game probably a better idea
would be something like Knight to e7 and
after a kick the Queen away from that
five play Queen to c2 now the Queen
assumed this very nice diagonal and she
can join the defense anytime she wants
but instead after this rook to d1 B Phi
was played and this allowed white Maria
a very important tempo she plays Knight
to h3 now threatening moves like Knight
to f4 Knight to g5 and there's a very
little black can do about this Knight to
e7 was played okay this does keep the
Queen Queen g4 and now Knight to f8 here
why does have a couple of options he can
either play a she can either play a
Knight to g5 Knight to f4 f4 immediately
as is an idea followed by a five but she
decides to go for Knight to f4 now with
the tempo on the rook rook the c6 and
now Queen captures on h4 she won back at
the pawn and the position is definitely
looking better for her Knight comes to
g6 now will attempt on the queen Knight
captures Knight captures and Queen to g4
we have worked da tand f4 and this is a
of course preparing f5 and the black
should really do something about this
but it's not at all clear what something
like rook to e8 maybe or Queen to c2 to
maybe try to help out with Queen somehow
but a5 was played immediately going for
that before and creating a passed pawn
but this simply doesn't work f5 now and
this is a this f5 move is a big problem
for black if you if you play something
like Knight to e7 then
six and you're in big trouble if you
play f6 Bishop to h6 is coming and white
is completely winning here and there is
no defense
so after F 5 meter decided to play
Knight captures on e5 giving up a piece
for two points pawn captures now we have
Queen captures and rug DT 1 now assuming
that open e file
Queen to d6 f6 now the threat is of
course Queen captures on g7 wood
checkmate g6 was played and now Queen to
h4 the ideas of course Queen comes to h6
and Queen to g7 checkmate so d4 was
played rook to e7 now as if you play
Queen to h6 immediately Queen to f8 is
defending checkmate so rook to e7 not
allowing the Queen to go back to f8 this
is very important although we are
winning you do want to you know you
don't you don't want to give black any
chances
Queen to c5 now and here this is a again
a nice opportunity for white to blunder
white played Bishop to g5 here if you
play the Queen to h5 now immediately it
seems like there's no stopping checkmate
but black actually has rook captures on
f6 that's the whole point of this Queen
to c5 idea and after rook captures on f6
you capture Queen a captures rook on e7
and you're still up a piece okay you do
have this bishop but to look at these
pawns when they start marching forward
that piece doesn't really give a white
any advantage so after a queen to c5
Bishop to g5 was played now rook
captures pawn isn't really a threat
because Bishop captures and the bishop
guards the rook and there's really
nothing for black to do here
d3 was played with check kind of
prolonging the game king h1 rook
captures Bishop captures now the threat
is a queen to h8 checkmate so Mitra for
some reason doesn't resign here she
plays Queen to h5 Queen captures G
captures and rook the e5 now
going for those pawns on the queenside
rook to d6 rook captures we have rook
captures on f6 rook captures and I don't
think a woman Grandmaster can really
think that those pawns can win against
the rooks but for some reason she still
doesn't resign before was played a
captures a captures rook to d5 we have B
3 and now rook to cease rook to b6 and
now in this position mitra has finally
resigned to the game as you can't really
push any pawns if you put this pawn the
works can pick up any of the points and
I mean you're down two rooks this is
this is ridiculous
but yeah definitely a great game by
Maria Florencia and always nice you know
being a higher rated opponent so so a
good game I do hope you enjoyed it if
you have any other suggestions for some
less known players
I feel free feel free to suggest them in
the comment section using the hashtag of
course thank y'all for watching as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and I will see you soon